Natoo : Salut !
Cyprien : Salut Nat !
Natoo : Ca va ?
Cyprien : Vas y rentre.
Cyprien : Tu veux un café, quelque chose?
Natoo : Non c'est bon..
Cyprien : Quoi ?
Natoo : Euh... je dois vous annoncer une nouvelle
Norman : Quoi ?!
Norman : C'est quoi cette grande nouvelle là ?
Natoo : Je sais pas si c'est une grande nouvelle.
En tout cas aujourd'hui avec Mathieu on a emménagé ensemble.
Cyprien : Sérieux ?!
Norman : Ah c'est cool !
Natoo : Bah ouais ! Ça fait un an qu'on est ensemble, donc normal quoi.
Cyprien : Attend, moi ça fait 7 ans que je suis avec Laurie
On vie pas ensemble, c'est pas grave hein..
Natoo : Ah ouais, 7 ans quand même !
Norman : Bah c'est vrai qu'en général au bout de 7 ans t'as un gosse hein
Cyprien : Non mais n'importe quoi vous, moi je veux pas de gamin !
Je ne saurais même pas m'en occuper
Norman : Bah, tu n'as qu'a t'entraîner !
Être adulte, c'est aussi être un père responsable
Cyprien : Owwnn ...Own c'est un bon bébé hein...
Il a faim le bon bébé ?
Norman : Euh.. t'sais quand j'disais ça t'étais pas obligé de direct humm..
Cyprien : Mais non mais t'as raison...
Si j'arrive pas à m'occuper d'un chien j'arrive pas à m'occuper d'un bébé. Tu peux pas prendre les croquettes ? Là, là..
Norman : Ouais, nan mais frère, c'est du taf. Ca fait du bruit, ça pue...
Euh... ça va tout saloper l'appart
Cyprien :  Nan. C'est mon appart.
Donc euh.. j'fais c'que j'veux.
Norman : Ouais, ok d'accord mais j'sais pas, imagine un soir, par exemple,
tu... ramènes une meuf...
Cyprien : Ouais. Mais ça fait 7 ans que j'suis avec ma copine, tu le sais, ça ?
Norman : Ok... imagine par exemple, euh... c'est moi qui ramène une meuf
Par exemple... tout à l'heure
Cyprien : Nan mais t'es chiant... J'avais prévu de rester en famille avec Aurélien là...
Hein, Aurélien ?
Norman : D'accord le chien s'appelle Aurélien...
C'est juste un chien hein...
Il a pas de cerveau, ça sert à rien de lui parler comme ça...
Il a pas de conscience tu vois...
Natoo : "Être un bon père" ?
Cyprien : Ouais.
C'est un livre super... Ça apprend à.. installer une relation de confiance
Entre le père et l'enfant du plus jeune âge...
Norman : Hein ? *croque une croquette*
Natoo : Owiie ! Oh non il te fait des bisous ! Oh t'es trop chou !
*Aurélien embrasse Natoo* Oh ! Oh non c'est trop mignon !
Norman : Ah ouais, vous me faites peur là...
Euh donc la meuf euuh... J'annule ou...?
Cyprien : C'est qui cette fille que tu dragues là ? Tu l'a rencontré comment ?
Norman : Ben en fait, j'regardais mes amis Facebook... Et après j'ai regardé
MES AMIS D'AMIS FACEBOOK. Et de fil en aiguille j'tombe sur mes
AMIS D'AMIS D'AMIS FACEBOOK parce que voilà quoi...
Cyprien : Parce que t'es un psychopathe...?
Norman : N'importe quoi. Et là je tombe, sur Inès Martinet
Natoo : Attend. GrandCorpsMalade ?
Norman : Ouais
Cyprien : C'est qui ça?
Natoo : Mais nannnnn
Natoo : Mais si c'était une meuf au collège... Une espèce de gothique un peu cheloue
Elle était tombée en cours d'EPS
et du coup avec mon amie on l'appelait "GrandCorpsMalade" jusqu'au brevet !
Cyprien : GrandCorpsMalade ah oui, j'm'en rappelle ! *rigole*
Norman : En tout, j'peux vous dire que GrandCorpsMalade est devenu...BeauCorpsBienFoutu
hein donc euh... fermez vos gueules
Cyprien : Eh, pas de gros mots devant le ptit hein !
Mathieu (le petit ami de Natoo) : Allô ? A-attend je sais si euh...
Tu me vois là ou pas ?
Natoo : *chuchote* Mais oui j'te vois...
Jte disais : ça pourrait être sympa que tu viennes...
Mathieu : Ah ouais...
mais en fait, mon amour j'suis complètement claqué et...
J'pense que j'vais dormir, ça me fera le plus grand bien..
Natoo : Mais Mathieu, il est que 19h30 là !
Mathieu : Tu sais quoi, amuse toi bien avec tes amis, d'accord ? *bruit assez chelous de bisous*
Cyprien : C'est joli ce petit.. ce ptit chemisier là..
Inès : C'est dingue ça... vous avez pas changé... et vous vous êtes jamais perdus de vue depuis le collège..
Norman : Ben non hein... moi j'suis hyper fidèle en amitié ! Bon pas qu'en amitié d'ailleurs ...
Inès : C'est à dire ?
Norman : Bah.. j'suis fidèle aussi...euh..
S-sur d'autres plans..
QUELQU'UN VEUT UN PTIT PEU DE HOUMOUS OU PAS ?
Cyprien : Et toi Inès d'ailleurs... tu fais de ta vie maintenant ?
Inès : Oh, bah que dire, que dire...
Moi j'étudie les marchés pour une grande banque d'investissement
WPTY.. euh on viens d'acheter un petit 90 mètres carrés...
Norman : Tu dis "On"..
T'as un ptit copain ou...
Inès : Ou-ouais ouais...
J'ai un petit copain, ouais..
J'ai un fiancé hein...
et on va se marier même
Norman : ah génial...
Natoo : Trop bien !
Cyprien : Ah bah bravo hein...
Natoo : Donc un "petit" 90 mètres carrés...
Inès : Ouais...
Bah forcément, on a prévu une chambre pour un enfant, tu vois...
Cyprien : Bah pareil ! Avec l'arrivée d'Aurélien, il me faut aussi une chambre en plus..
Inès : T'as un petit garçon?
Cyprien : Ouais !
J'vais le castrer, j'pense...
Natoo : Euh, oui c'est un chien, avant que t'appelles la police heu...
Cyprien : D'ailleurs, il fait plus de bruit, j'pense qu'il dort...
Oh, en plus j'lui ai pas mis de couche...
Norman : Quand tu dis "On va se marier" t'es sûre de ce choix parce que c'est quand même un truc important dans une vie...?
Inès : Oui mais là je...je sens que c'est le moment tu vois
Norman : Même avec tous les divorces qu'y a ?
Inès : Ouais, mais j'aime tellement mon homme...
Norman : ah ouais..
Inès : Ouais il est super, il a une vie incroyable...
Mais d'ailleurs vous voyez ptêt qui c'est...c'est le mois de février dans le calendrier des pompiers de Paris
Natoo : *choquée* AH OUAIS ?
Inès : Ouais
Natoo : Haaannn... Ouais je vois très bien..
Inès : Celui qui est torse nu avec la lance à incendie
Natoo : Avec les gros pecs là ?
Inès : Tu vois ? Ouais ! C'est lui !
Norman : Moi j'avais fais le casting, justement...
Inès : D'accord.
Cyprien : Uh...Aurélien, il a pissé partout !
Inès : Alors, vous savez c'qui serait super ?
Que vous veniez tous à mon mariage !!
Tous ensemble : Ah ouais ?
Inès : Ouais, ça me ferait super plaisir ! Pour se rappeler
du bon vieux temps où on savait pas quoi faire de notre vie..Ca vous dit ?
Natoo : Hmm...
Norman : Moi j'ai hâte personnellement..
Inès : Ouh làlà ! Faut que je file moi !
Ca m'a fait super plaisir de vous voir ! Salut !
A bientôt !
Natoo : Au mariage quoi...
Norman : Salut !
Inès : Super ! Tchao !
Cyprien : Ouais super...
*soupir*
Quelqu'un reveux du houmous?
Laurie (petite copine de Cyprien) : Cypriennn ! Salut c'est moi .. !
Ca va ?
Ben vous en faites une tête...qu'est ce qui s'passe?
Tout vas bien, à part que GrandCorpsMalade vas se marier avec une sorte de pompier
extrêmement musclé. Voilà.
Natoo : Elle a un taf de ouf et elle vit
dans un "petit" 90 mètres carrés...
Cyprien : Notre fils a pissé partout..
Laurie : Notre fils ressemble beaucoup au chien de la voisine...
*bâillement*
Cyprien : Au revoir, Aurélien...
*le chien parait triste* #Jambon